[Applaudissements]
j'imagine que personne n'a comprise que
je veux dire probablement que vous êtes
senti très mal à l'aise gêné et surtout
en tout à la compréhension
c'est exactement ce que j'ai ressenti
les deux premiers mois où je suis
devenue sourde
en effet en juillet 2017 je suis parti
faire un stage humanitaire au kenya ma
mission était d'enseigner les
mathématiques et l'anglais dans un
orphelinat du bidonville de nairobi
nommé kibera cependant après trois
semaines j'en étais à apprendre à
enseigner les tables de multiplication
hammam à classer mes enfants de cet
orphelinat
j'en étais aussi à découvrir les
différentes beauté de ce pays comme par
exemple donner à manger aux girafes
mais après ces trois semaines je n'ai
pas pu continuer d'enseigner les tables
de multiplication à lyndon brian dsl ou
maxwell
je n'ai pas pu continuer d'enseigner la
lecture à néma sheila ou barak
en effet après une semaine
d'hospitalisation au kenya suite à une
méningite bactérienne dont une journée
dans le coma j'ai dû leur dire au revoir
la méningite bactérienne est une maladie
mortelle qui nécessite une action rapide
et une action d'antibiotiques en
intraveineuse pour avoir une chance de
rester en vie tout ce dont je me
rappelle aujourd'hui si d'avoir des
migraines insupportable d'avoir mal à la
nuque et le dos bloqué d'avoir une
d'être de la lumière ce soit
insupportable en fait à regarder de la
lumière je commence ensuite à me mettre
à vomir avant d'être envoyés d'urgence
en ambulance au kenya je me réveille
ensuite une journée plus tard avec des
files branche est partout et les
médecins me disent que j'ai une
infection bactérienne sur une échelle
avec un taux qui est supérieur à ce qui
est toléré par le corps humain avec ses
premiers mots que les médecins me disent
je me rend aussi compte que je n'entends
pas un mot de ce qu'on me dit après une
semaine d'hospitalisation muneta ne
s'était pas améliorée j'avais perdu 6
kilos je n'entendais toujours pas ce
qu'on me disait et j'avais même arrêter
de parler quand on vend donc plus qu on
me disait j'avais perdu le goût de
communiquer ma famille et les médecins
donc décidé de me rapatrier en france
laval le bilan était sans appel j'ai
survécu à une méningite bactérienne mais
je suis devenu malentendantes
c'est un bilan vraiment très lourd
irréversible mais surtout très accablant
quand on a seulement 22 ans
comme je me suis présenté il ya quelques
secondes je suis devenu malentendantes à
l'âge de 22 ans après être retourné en
france
avec ce nouveau bilan de cette nouvelle
vie est arrivé donc un nouveau cycle
d'émotions et de sentiments auxquels mon
entourage et moi-même n'étions pas prêts
d affronter en effet au début tout ce
que je ressentais c'était de la colère
et de la frustration
je me disais tout simplement mais
pourquoi c'est arrivé à moi pourquoi
maintenant mais surtout pourquoi moi
pourquoi moi je me disais mais je pense
qu'on va être une bonne personne je
partais d'ailleurs au kenya faire de
l'humanitaire alors pourquoi moi j'avais
beaucoup de questions auxquelles je ne
trouvais pas de réponse est vraiment
voir les lèvres de mes parents
j'ai pour certainement essayer de me
réconforter me consoler sans entendre un
mot de ce qu'il me disait était vraiment
très frustrant
ensuite je suis passé à l'étape du déni
je ne voulais pas accepter ma situation
je ne voulais absolument pas me définir
comme malentendantes et je voulais
encore moins porter des appareils
auditifs
pour moi c'était la pire chose qui
pouvait m'arriver c'était de me rendre
compte que je ne pouvais plus être la
femme que j'étais avant sans faire
certains ajustements ensuite de ça et
passer donc l'étape de l'acceptation et
du lâcher prise
je ne pouvais plus nier ce qui
m'arrivait pourquoi tout simplement
parce que j'ai été confronté à des
situations difficiles qui m'empêchait de
nier ce qui m'arrivait et qui me pousser
à accepter comme par exemple le fait
d'aller en cours à l'université et de ne
pas entendre un seul mot de ce que me
dit mes professeurs qui sont juste
devant moi parce que j'ai choisi de
prendre les places devant pour
m'encourager à les entendre ou encore
être vraiment très mal à l'aise dans la
rue car je ne comprends pas mais je ne
reconnais pas non plus tous les bruits
de l'environnement j'étais donc obligés
d'accepter
je n'avais pas d'autre choix j'ai
ensuite décidé de passer à l'action
j'ai fait plusieurs choses pour m'aider
à accepter cette situation et à
continuer d'aller de l'avant et de vivre
cette nouvelle vie j'ai pris par exemple
le challenge de faire les jeux du
commerce chose que j'avais décidé de
faire avant même de devenir
malentendantes
mais bien sûr ce petit handicap s'est
ajoutée une difficulté j'ai pris le
challenge de quand même le faire puis
finalement avec mon équipe nous avons
fini premier j'ai ensuite décidé de
partager sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui
m'est arrivé pour tout simplement tenir
au courant mon entourage de ma situation
est aussi pouvoir les sensibiliser j'ai
aussi fait des shooting photo pour
mettre sur photos des émotions que j'ai
ressenti à ce moment là pour plus faire
un travail de développement personnel et
d'accepter ce que je ressentais j'ai
aussi décidé de
une chaîne youtube sur lequel j'explique
tous les changements que ça implique
dans mon quotidien de devenir
malentendantes
du jour au lendemain où j'explique mes
coups de gueule mais galère mais aussi
mes anecdotes comme par exemple le fait
de pendant huit heures de temps dans un
avion ne pas pouvoir regarder un film
car la compagnie aérienne en question ne
propose que des écouteurs ce qui ne
marche pas très bien avec des appareils
auditifs
si j'ai décidé d'être otsi proactive
dans mes changements et dans ce
bouleversement de vie c'est tout
simplement pour aller de l'avant ne pas
me morfondre sur mon sort et aussi
trouver une certaine force intérieure
pour aller de l'avant
cependant par nous j'ai aussi continuer
à faire de la médecine parallèle et donc
des médecines douces si on peut le dire
pour aider dans mon second
dans la seconde c'est qu'elle en fait de
cette méningite qui sont les acouphènes
les acouphènes ce sont en fait des
bruits qui sont produits par mon cerveau
mais que je suis la seule à pouvoir
percevoir comme vous pouvez voir ici sur
cette photo j'ai commencé des séances
d'acupuncture pour essayer de réduire
ses acouphènes puisque si on réfléchit
bien j'ai perdu de l'audition que je
n'entends plus mais d'un autre côté
j'entends des bruits 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 que je suis la seule à
pouvoir entendre le cam n'existe plus
dans ma vie et en plus je n'entends pas
donc j'essaye tout ce qui est possible
de faire je prends des actions j'ai fait
du yoga
j'ai vu des ostéopathes j'ai fait des
séances de magnétiseur en ce moment je
fais de l'acupuncture la seule et
dernière étape qu'il me reste si tout
cela ne marche pas ça serait l'hypnose
pour essayer de retrouver un petit peu
de calme dans ma vie une normalité est
cependant tout ceci il que je viens de
vous énoncez n'est pas linéaire de temps
en temps il m'arrive de retomber dans la
colère et la frustration et de retombées
d'un moniteur mes interrogations
il m'arrive aussi de retourner dans le
déni et je vais parfois refusées
de porter mes appareils auditifs pendant
toute une journée si je reste à la
maison par exemple c'est quand même plus
pratique
pensez seulement à l'intérieur ensuite
de ça dans cette société
je me suis rendu compte que souvent les
personnes ne sont pas prêts à nous
laisser accuser le coup et à comprendre
ce qui nous arrive
je me rappelle très bien pour mon
entourage me disait mines on regarde ça
va mieux
la voiture qui passe juste à côté de toi
tu l'entends donc ça va ou alors ils me
disaient oh le matin tu pourrais te
réveiller en te disant ça va mieux
aujourd'hui
cependant ce n'était pas vrai du tout
non seulement ça ne m'aidait pas mais en
plus ça me faisait encore plus
culpabiliser de ne pas me sentir bien
avec cette nouvelle étape dans ma vie
que je vivais puis un jour j'ai
rencontré une personne qui m'a dit tu
sais amandine ce que tu as vécu c'est
vraiment traumatisant tu es vraiment
très jeune donc tu as le droit d'être en
colère aux frustrés de temps en temps
c'est ton droit et personne ne peut te
l'enlever à ce moment là c'est facile à
dire comme phrase ça peut paraître
ordinaire mais c'est là que j'ai tout
compris
j'ai compris que si je voulais m'adapter
à cette nouvelle vie ça passait par
accepter ce que je vivais réellement
après tout s'adapter à une situation
difficile
c'est accepter de ressentir et accepter
le sentiment qu'on ressent lie à ce
bouleversement lié à ce changement
ensuite l'étape de l'adaptation c'est
l'étape l'étape qui suit l'action et
pour moi c'est passé par faire le tri
dans mes amis en effet j'ai décidé de
garder des relations très proches avec
les personnes qu'ils m'apportent que
j'ai besoin maintenant que je suis mal
entendantes c'est à dire de la
compréhension et à la patience et
surtout beaucoup de positivisme
j'ai aussi décidé d'écarter les
personnes qui dans ma vie prenez sur le
ton de la rigolade ce qui m'est arrivé
était très négatif ou qui ne me laissait
pas exprimer ce que je ressentais en
effet avec ce qui m'est arrivé s'il ya
bien quelque chose que j'ai à
prix c'est que la vie est vraiment très
courte et qu'il faut en profiter
alors moi j'ai décidé de passer ma vie
avec les personnes qui vous veulent du
bien ensuite j'ai pu remarquer que ce
n'est pas donné à tout le monde de
comprendre ma situation est d'arriver à
s'adapter
il ya des personnes comme ma petite
soeur noémie qui elle a tout de suite
compris ce qui m'arrive et a réussi à
s'adapter très rapidement
par exemple si nous marchons dans la rue
et qu'il ya un bruit de klaxon ou un
bruit parasite comme j'aime les appeler
elle va subitement arrêté de parler
parce qu'elle sait que je ne vais pas du
tout entendre ce qu'elle va dire en
effet les son environnement en
retournant et les bruits prennent la
place des paroles des gens des personnes
comme ma soeur savent très bien
s'adapter à moi et ont une certaine
empathie envers moi cependant je pense
qu en me voyant arriver ici vous ne vous
doutiez pas du tout que je suis mal
entendantes maintenant en effet mon
handicap n'est pas quelque chose de
visible
je comprends alors que pour mon
entourage ce n'est pas facile de
s'adapter à moi et ça rend la tâche
encore plus difficile
ce changement est difficile pour eux
c'est donc en fait un principe d'
empathie des deux parties prenantes
si une adaptation à faire des deux
parties et c'est comme je dirais une
double en pratique il faut avoir
je comprends que ce soit difficile pour
eux donc je suis plus indulgente
mais il doit comprendre ce qu'est dans
ma vie maintenant mais j'ai besoin qu'on
me répète les choses parfois mais dans
cette société très exigeante où tout va
très très vite
j'avais vraiment l'impression qu'on ne
me laissait pas le temps d'être celle
que je suis maintenant parfois
j'entendais mais amandine où sont passés
tes rires tu es joie de vivre c'est bon
c'est pas la fin du monde
cette phrase c'est pas la fin du monde
personne n'a envie d'entendre ça soit là
et j'avais juste envie de répondre mais
en fait que laissez moi le temps
laissez-moi digérer laissez-moi accusé
le coup oui ça va aller mieux comme vous
le dites mais laissez-moi du temps en
fait selon moi
c'était très important de trouver mes
propres astuces pour aller de l'avant et
retrouver cette force intérieure de
continuer d'avancer et d'être celle que
je suis mais avec une ouïe et en moins
j'ai donc trouvé mes propres astuces
en effet le matin en me levant je ne me
dis pas ça va mieux aujourd'hui comme
une proposait mais ça va aller mieux
aujourd'hui la différence verbalement
minimes mais psychologiquement vraiment
très importante
aussi j'ai décidé vraiment de prendre du
temps pour moi j'ai décidé comme astuce
de continuer d'être la femme que je suis
avec les personnes qui me veulent du
bien mais aujourd'hui si je suis ici
si vous vous rappelez bien je vous
disais certaines de mes interrogations
pourquoi c'est arrivé à moi tout ça
finalement j'ai trouvé une réponse
selon moi c'est pour raconter mon
histoire la partager à ceux qui veulent
bien l'écouter comme vous ici par
exemple c'est pour trouver ma propre
force intérieure d'aller de l'avant mais
aussi aider les autres à trouver la leur
ce que je vous propose c'est pour
n'importe quelle difficulté que vous
allez rencontrer dans votre vie c'est
d'être proactifs d'être le maître de
votre changement et de votre propre
bien-être
mais s'il vous plaît je vous demanderais
aussi de ne pas être comme cette société
exigeante que j'ai pu remarquer vous ne
savez pas ce que vit votre voisin à côté
de vous les changements auxquels il est
il si l'ogc lequel il subit vous ne le
savez pas donc soyez indulgent avec les
gens autour de vous finalement
aujourd'hui j'ai 23 ans maintenant je ne
regrette absolument pas d'avoir fait mon
stage humanitaire au kenya j'ai fini mes
études ici à acheter
j'ai trouvé un emploi oui je suis mal
entendantes oui je porte la paille
rotatif mais surtout aujourd'hui à 7
secondes maintenant avec vous ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que je vais très
bien et vous
comment allez vous réellement merci à
manger alain
[Applaudissements]